all right haste full stack haskell for
non-phd candidates anybody in here have
a phd
yes any candid phd candidates in the
room
all right well you have to plug your
ears this talk is not for you it's for
all the rest of you out there
a little bit about us um i want to talk
about us just for a little bit uh just
so you understand the sort of
perspective that we're coming from and
giving this talk
um
i
am that sporting young gentleman on the
left-hand side less young now than i was
then
um
i did my the primary
majority of my undergraduate work at
bellevue community college outside
seattle rounded that out with uh
bachelors of arts in business and
inspiration um it's a joke we're having
formal computer science or mathematics
training uh
i've been working with haskell for about
a year now um
i'm an industry i consider myself an
industry web application developer i've
been
in the web application space writing
java and ruby and javascript and python
and a little bit of skull this time the
other greater part of about 15 years
got into haskell earlier this year just
sort of getting frustrated with the
languages
day-to-day and with all the buzz about
functional programming they were coming
across my newsfeed i was kind of
interested in like
finding out what it had to offer so
doing like the
right your ecis 194 ports which i highly
recommend
um in some scholars stuff and doing a
learning haskell book and going through
real world hassle some of the other
leaders who are out there sort of at
this point in which i didn't know what
to do next i wanted to build some stuff
from doing regular web applications all
initially these last number of years
stumbled across and it sort of made a
good fit so sort of an expose on our
findings
and i have a similar background i've
been doing
software development for about 18 years
mostly in java
lately and go
like two pariah languages at this
conference um
and uh
you know but i i went to strange loop
three years ago and and uh
and
you know got immersed in in some of the
functional programming world and got
interested in haskell and joe armstrong
had that slide where he had that triad
of properties of languages uh yesterday
where it was you know i think it was
performance uh productivity and safety
right and and there's this allure of of
haskell and and it's you know
predecessors
uh in the safety category right like
it's got this really crazy type system
it's got this effects system and it it's
you know gets you really close to
feeling like your programs are really
solid and that you're kind of a you know
a real computer scientist as opposed to
some sort of joker you know getting paid
to to write software and coblet together
right so it's got this allure
but
it's not very approachable at least it
wasn't approachable to me with my
background and and i
trump his educational background i have
taken one computer science course at the
university of missouri in pascal in
1995. so i mean i've got the foundation
uh but uh i still found haskell to be
very very difficult to get started with
um and so this talk and what we're
hoping to do in this talk is to give you
if you're interested in haskell and
you're seeing
these talks at this conference that are
haskell or haskell derivatives we want
to give you the confidence to feel that
you can go back and learn this language
on your own there's lots of resources
online and that you are smart enough to
do it because if we can stand up here
and give a talk like if alex miller
picks us to give this talk then you
absolutely can go back and and and learn
this language on your own so that's
that's our goal here today
all right so uh aside from that um we're
gonna give you a high-level overview of
the haste uh api and we're gonna give it
actually some concrete examples how to
do things like web sockets and uh dawn
manipulation and
uh dealing with local storage and all
that stuff it'll look pretty similar to
what you would find like the python
cookbook or ruby on rails by examples
where we're just gonna just blast
through code samples we're not gonna
explain a lot of theory behind it but we
hopefully we're going to present them in
a way that you can uh your interest is
sort of
you think to yourself like i can use
this tool i can build like basic web
application stuff with this
um and we're going to present these
examples in such a way you don't have to
know a bunch of password syntax i'm not
going to use the m word i'm not going to
use any of those words that appear in a
bunch of blogs or talks or whatever i
don't think it's actually necessary for
you just getting the basics uh banged
out with a tool like case and once you
get the basics down then you can
backfill with some of the theory later
um okay so those goals non-goals we're
not going to be teaching you haskell
today um we'll teach you enough hassle i
suppose that you can sort of like fumble
your way through the examples uh with us
but enough javascript will be shown on
the screen next to the hassle but i
don't think it'll be too difficult for
you to do the mental mapping between the
two languages
um i'm not going to try to explain
northeast uh how the hands compiler
works because i don't really know if
you're super interested in it
the uh the author of the tool has
written some papers on the subject so
you can go deep dive into that but
that's outside of the scope of this talk
um and additionally i'm not gonna try to
advocate
best practices so i'm not gonna try to
like give examples of how to structure a
larger application um that you may you
know cobble together from components
paste i'm gonna i'm gonna just show you
the the basics of uh of what you can do
with this tool and then you'll go the
next step when you leave this room and
build really awesome things
all right so
what is haste um haste is is a couple
different things
first and foremost haste is a haskell to
javascript compiler um the author of the
the tool refers to it as a dialect of
the haskell programming language so
you're going to be able to use most of
the things that you're familiar with if
you're already using haskell
and in fact much of package will compile
with the haste compiler in addition to
that what you're going to get is a
library that will
the library whose api will allow you to
do things like manipulate the dom
do event listening on dom elements
interface with local storage ajax and
all that other good stuff and that's the
standard library that's included with
tool
a little bit of history about haste
because i'm presenting of somebody's
tool that i didn't write myself and i
should give them a little shout out it
was written by anton ekblod while he was
doing his research at the university of
gothenburg um the purpose of the tool
from my perspective was to uh a couple
different things first and foremost
allow you to write
a javascript client with haskell
the author feels i believe that uh there
are some advantages of writing a a web
application with haskell instead of
javascript i won't get into that debate
the other thing that he talks about in
his paper is
authoring as a single program a
overall web application that spans both
client and server
if that's something you're really
interested in i encourage you to go
check out the the work that uh anton and
his co-conspirators have done on this
we're not going to be talking about that
particular aspect of haste but it is
very interesting instead we're going to
be focusing on um the
stuff that you're going to be doing
programming against the uh web browser
apis the document object and so on and
so forth
all right
and so before we get in we're going to
just do a quick crash course of basic
hassle syntax and one thing that i also
want to say before we get too far into
this is this is not an advocacy talk so
we're not up here saying that you should
go home and write a bunch of apps in
haste not that you shouldn't either but
there are a bunch of languages that
compile to javascript there's been two
other talks today
evan gave that talk on elm and frp this
morning
and bodil gave the talk on pure script
and the author of purescript maybe in
this room
yes
back there so
and those are great tools and what we're
going to show you here because those
both of those languages are haskell
derived what we're going to show here
applies more or less to those tools as
well so if you went to the purescript
talk and maybe didn't get all the slides
this stuff is going to help you out as
well and we're going to be very there
aren't a lot of slides on this stuff so
um and if you know haskell this is going
to be super boring so you can pull your
computer out and do other stuff
um so what does this look like this is
that first line where we've
spelled double there that that is the
name of a function so we're that's a
function declaration so the name of the
function and then the two colons and
then the type integer and the arrow and
then another type integer so this is an
example of a function that takes one
parameter
of type integer and returns an integer
okay and the implementation is the line
below so
x is the parameter and the definition of
the function on the right side of the
equal sign
is x times t
so that's
the very basics of defining a haskell
function
and if we were to run it in the reple
it does what you would expect
so what happens if we have two two
parameters um
we start to add arrows and this is one
interesting difference uh you know if
you're coming from other languages uh
where it you know you're used to seeing
parameters separated from return types
right you're used to seeing like a comma
b and then maybe a colon or something
some other syntactic element and then
the return type and
haskell and haskell
derived languages don't don't look like
that instead you've got these arrow
separators and there's a reason for that
but this function does what you might
expect it takes x and y and adds them
together
but this enables a certain property
currying or partial application where
you don't have to supply all of the
arguments
when you make the call so the first
example that we've got in the repple
here of add 10 and 5
that's just sort of a normal
function execution but then we've got
this binding this let add 10 equals add
10 and and that's essentially a
partially applied function so it's
another function and that function is
going to take a single integer and
return an integer so we basically um we
if we call add 10 with with 15 we get
25.
and that's a trick that that haskell is
going to employ
all over the place
other little things to know uh
you know so if you've got the built-in
function higher order function map
and uh the stuff in parentheses after
that
is a lambda function so an anonymous
function that takes a single parameter
and adds to you to it and then the stuff
in square brackets uh is is an array of
numbers that will be passed into that
mapping function and the code on the
right side is sort of the moral
equivalent
of the job in javascript so
on the left we have the haskell syntax
and on the right we have sort of the
equivalent javascript
then down below we've got another
example and this is the dollar signs you
may have seen in the purescript talk
and that's simply just used to
sort of separate out
components of execution and it's sort of
morally equivalent to the code on the
right where we've got them grouped in
parentheses
so
the lambda there that's highlighted in
yellow is equivalent to the the function
on the write in javascript
and then we've got some examples of sort
of how those dollar signs sort of reduce
when when this code is parsed at compile
time
so congratulations you probably now know
more haskell than all your co-workers do
you can go back to the office and tell
them that you learned all sorts of
interesting things a strange loop you
can grow yourself a great beard or put
on a wizard hat or whatever
but at this point i think you know
enough that you can as i mentioned sort
of like
worm your way through the examples with
us
okay so you're totally convinced after
seeing those couple slides that haskell
is really awesome and now you want to
build some stuff with haste because
we've hyped it up so much what are you
to do
first thing you wanted to do is go and
get haskell on your computer you do this
with homebrew or you download it from
the haskell website that's going to come
with cabal which is package manager for
haskell and you'll use cabal to install
haste
after you do that you run haste boot
haste boot downloads the entire internet
and you're now ready to write some some
haskell that'll turn into a web
application
okay so uh we're gonna go through the
canonical haste hello world will
gradually get more and more and more uh
complicated as i show you the different
apis you could be working with
we're going to start off with just
hello.html which is not really going to
have a lot going on all it's going to do
is essentially contain a script tag with
a source that points to hello.js which
is a file that we have not yet authored
we're going to crack open our favorite
text editor and write our first haskell
program um
i would imagine you can look at this
code not know any haskell and just
assume like what it's going to do
if what you thought was that it's going
to alert hello world in a web browser
you are totally correct
um an important thing to note here is
this import haste and what that's going
to do is it's going to give you access
to all of the uh hey standard library
this is stuff that's going to allow you
to interact with the dom do local
storage ajax and all that other good
stuff
um
i point hey c and go back to my command
line i point hey c at that hello.hs
some compilation happens and out comes
hello.js which is that file that i
referenced in my uh in my html page so
not surprisingly i opened this file up
haskell's compiled down to javascript
and now i get hello world in the web
browser
right pretty pretty awesome
thank you for that for that pity clap
it gets better i swear
okay so hey spy example um one thing i
want to know before i jump into all the
examples uh if there are any um haskell
graybeards in this audience my apologies
this is going to be the most imperative
like beat you over the head lame looking
haskell examples of all time but i think
they are examples that are approachable
to people coming from imperative
language backgrounds
i found that when i was trying to learn
haskell and trying to take steps past
the the basic tutorials and the yorgi
course and learn new and haskell and so
on and so forth like there were just too
many things coming at me at one time i
was having a very difficult time
separating what these libraries were
providing from uh
other concepts like applicative functor
and so on and so forth that had their
own set of operator looking things that
i was having a difficult time wrapping
my head around so all these examples are
super imperative looking
you don't have to do it this way but
it'll help you sort of grok what's going
on
all right first thing we're going to do
we're going to manipulate the dom and
we're going to do some event listening
so going back to an html file we're
going to do catpix.html
and i wasn't i wasn't around for all of
yesterday but it came to my attention
that wolf from alfred is able to take a
cat picture and turn it by a certain
number of degrees we will demonstrate
that with haskell you can go way beyond
what's possible
with that with that language
okay so script tag pointing at catpix.js
we've got some css
the interesting thing here that's
different about the prior example is
that i've got this div with an id of
root sitting inside this body element
okay so uh i'm going to step through
these examples and in the beginning i'm
going to show haskell on the left-hand
side and the sort of moral equivalent
javascript on the hand side this is not
what haste will compile to haste will
compile to some rocket science stuff
that you will not understand that does
not look anything like this but this
will help you sort of do the mental
mapping between the api provided to you
by haste and what you've already been
doing in javascript for the last you
know 12 15 years or whatever
okay so starting at the top
we're going to call with alum we're
going to give it a string root which is
going to correspond to the id of some
element that we stash in the dom
james gave you that example of a lambda
so that little like slashy thing with
root it's an anonymous function with a
single parameter named root and what i
expect is when i find that element in
the dom i'm going to have access to it
via root
javascript on the right hand side shows
what's going on for those of you that
still need like you know some examples
of uh of how this stuff is working from
one language to the other but we're
gonna look in the dom if we can't find
this thing we're gonna blow up if we do
we just proceed on down
okay so once we find that element um
we're going to create ourselves a new
element using the new lm function we're
going to bind that to the name img we're
going to set some attributes on it we're
going to set a source we're going to set
an id and we're going to take this
element and we're going to attach it to
the dom element with id of root that we
already stashed in the dom
and you can look at the right hand side
and you can see that like the api for
let's say uh adding uh the image as a
child to the root element it looks very
similar it feels very familiar for
you've been if you've ever done the old
school style like bare bones javascript
interacting with like the document
object
then we're going to add some listeners
so when i move my mouse over the image
tag i'm going to set a class on that
image this class is going to be spin and
when i move my mouse out i'm going to
remove that class
from that image
i've used every css feature that i could
possibly get to make this
make this demo so we'll just crack it
open and see what it does
we got a cat
wolf from alfred can make it turn a
little bit
we can make it go all the way around
just think of the possibilities that's
the clap that is the clap that i wanted
thank you
all right going a little bit further um
as i mentioned uh you've got all the
building blocks to construct a basic
javascript web application you would run
your browser um manipulating the dom uh
doing event handling interfacing with
local storage so quick example of that
let's say we start out with an html page
with a couple elements in there an input
field with an id of in a save button and
a load button
familiar-looking code from that past
example we start with our with elements
we give it some strings it's going to
find some elements in the dom by those
id's we're going to attach a click
handler to the save button we're going
to pass it a lambda which is you know
equivalent to this uh anonymous function
expression that you're seeing on the
right-hand side in javascript what we're
going to do is we're going to get when
you click that when you click that save
button we're going to get the value of
that input
field of type text we're going to bind
its value to this name message and then
we're going to use that value
via message to set a value in local
storage
with using the key foo
then when some poor fool clicks on the
load button we're going to execute this
other anonymous function expression
which is going to get the value out of
local storage foo stash it excuse me
bind it to message if we get a value
we're going to use that value to set
to set some text in the dom otherwise
we're going to no op
and what that looks like
is not quite as exciting as spinning
cats but you could do hello strange loop
and i save it
and then let me open it up in some other
thing here and i load it
we got local storage so you can sort of
see like the building blocks are sort of
being laid out here um i totally screwed
that up let's see if i can find my
slides good
local storage um ajax another thing that
i thought was going to be total rocket
science with haste but turns out to be
the api that's provided to you is
relatively simple um starting out
getting some elements from the dom i'm
not going to show you what the
javascript looks like you can sort of
figure this out when i click the submit
button i'm going to execute this lambda
and what this lambda is going to do is
it's going to fire off an xhr
using the browser's xhr stuff
to slash api when i get a response back
i'm going to do some pattern matching if
i get a value i'm going to use that
value to set some text in the dom
otherwise i'm going to clear the text in
the dom and i conveniently started this
web server before we got here but if we
were to look at network traffic this is
just simple like http traffic uh regular
hsr xhr stuff but you know you're
authoring this code in haskell
if you were to get the types wrong for
instance of the uh function expression
that you're passing to the text request
things will blow up at compile time yada
yada
final toy example um we'll be
interacting with the html5 canvas um
we'll start by looking for an element in
the dom by id the
element id happens to be canvas
creatively
we're going to have a hook to that dom
element we're going to get a 2d drawing
context are you familiar with the html5
api right now
can't context and so on and so forth
okay some of you all right then we're
going to kick off our animation by
calling our animate function whose
implementation we'll get into in a
second passing this context
and a double and this double is going to
represent the degrees from top dead
center that we're going to spin this
thing so eventually we're going to you
know spin this animation we're going to
create an animation that spins a box
around a circle
i'll give you the types
just so
it kind of makes a little bit of sense
what's going on because this this is
where like our demos start to diverge
from things that look like javascript um
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to call a square function which is
going to return us a shape a shape is
essentially a function that is waiting
for a context and when it gets a context
it's going to uh create a path inside
that context
we're going to call stroke with that
resulting shape and that's going to give
us back a picture it's going to take
that path and draw some line around it
then we're going to rotate it
and rotate takes a double which is the
number of degrees from top dead center
and it takes a picture and it's going to
return a new picture that's been rotated
but once again this picture thing is
just a function waiting for a context so
you'll see that we're actually just
building up a bigger and bigger and
bigger function until we hit render
which passes canvas in which has got our
context and then we actually get some
stuff spinning around in your web
browser
the spinning around the web browser
stuff is achieved by doing a set timeout
10 and doing a recursive call to animate
canvas with a slightly
more tilted angle
so what that looks like i couldn't get
spinning cats within cats within cats
but you've got some boxes demonstrates
basic usage of the html5 canvas
um and of course like if you do anything
interesting and new in javascript these
days in the browser you have to show to
nbc so i started writing to mvc i wanted
to demo it to you but i was writing some
codes and that turned into some codes
that turned into some more codes and
then more codes we got more codes we got
more codes because i'm probably pretty
bad at haskell so i figured i'd just
show you the demo anyways um and this
thing is just basic to mvc so call mom
call dad and have panic
attack on stage
and i think i'm about done with that one
so but uh as searching around on the
internet i found some code examples uh
that people some examples of stuff that
people had written that are much smarter
than me um this fellow nathan huxton
whose name i'm totally butchering on
jshaskal.blogspot.com put together this
really cool demo of uh breakout
i'm terrible i'm
at this but this is built with netwire
and haste so pretty cool stuff
and certainly more interesting than to
do nbc which we've seen about 50
bajillion times and netwire was
mentioned uh evan mentioned that in the
talk this morning if you were at the frp
talk so it's one of these what was it an
arrowized frp library
that's just uh pure haskells so we'll
get into using
regular haskell libraries in a minute
but uh this example happens to do that
oh it's my turn
it's true that was slick
um
okay so this is a good segue so you know
part of the examples that aaron's been
showing you um
you would not write javascript like that
today right or if you did
well you might be doing it wrong you
might be doing it wrong right so there's
a ton of javascript libraries out there
now things like jquery to the more
advanced things obviously like angular
or react um and
and so what you kind of want you know
most of these transcompilation tools
provide you with some escape hatch that
lets you uh call into
existing javascript code and that's
called the ffi foreign function
interface so
we'll talk about that a little bit and
how it works in haste so
uh the haste ffi is bidirectional
which means that you can call regular
javascript code from your haste code you
can also export functions that you
author in haste and call them from
regular javascript code
the first
direction i think is the more common
direction the common use case would be
to wrap an existing javascript library
so you've got something like jquery or
something like d3
and you write bindings for it
and that would allow you to call into it
from your haste code and haste provides
two different ways to do ffi and we'll
look at both of them uh in a moment here
and they're they're called c call
and then the other one is uh ffi it's
called ffi conveniently it is
so we'll start with c call
um c call the the workflow is that you
write your your haskell code
as normal and you write a javascript
file uh manually that contains a set of
global functions that you want to call
and these are non-name space these have
to just exist
as global functions and then you pass a
flag to the haste compiler and it will
inline that javascript file into the
generated javascript output so we've got
an example down here
where we're using this with js flag
we're passing in a reference to this
hello ffijs file
so that's how the tooling works
so an example of this we've got hello hs
and that first line there is this kooky
line that says for an import c call and
then everything after that is a function
signature okay so we're saying that
there is a foreign function defined in
this external javascript file called add
that accepts two integers and returns an
integer
and we won't go into the notation of
this i o and the parentheses notation
for practical purposes just think of it
as returning an end
and
down below then we've got our main
method uh which looks a lot like the
examples that aaron gave and if we go
down to the bottom uh the sort of the
important line is that some line where
we're we're calling add so we're calling
add reading in the value from two
different boxes uh that we put in
index.html over there and then we're
setting a property uh on our output uh
span and uh that is the sum that was
computed and so the important bit is
that that add function does not exist
it's not defined anywhere in our in our
haskell file instead it's defined in
that lower right hand box hello ffi dot
js and it's kind of what you would
expect so we've got this add function
that takes x and y and returns the sum
by contrast you can use the ffi notation
and in this one it's almost exactly the
same the big difference is that you
don't need this external javascript file
that instead you're inlining uh some
javascript code as a string uh inside of
the haskell file so
we say that that we still have our
function declaration it's the same as in
the previous slide only we actually have
a definition for it here where we call
this ffi function provided by haste and
then we inline some javascript and that
javascript will get included in the
compiled output
and then everything down below is
exactly the same as it was on the
previous slide
and when we compile the example we don't
have to reference any external files so
useful if you want to do things like
instantiate a date
such that you can get the time from the
browser you don't have to manage another
javascript file and these flags
things like that that fit squarely like
within the concisely within the haskell
source itself right right and and so
just a brief comparison and again this
has started getting above our pay grade
like um the c call syntax is borrowed
from the normal haskell compilers uh cfi
that's why it has that name so it's
normally used to make a c call um
but the the author of haste sort of
exposed that same machinery um and
allowed you to use it with javascript
global functions
by contrast ffi is a library function
provided by the haste standard library
that'll be called at runtime and it has
a slight performance penalty but it
avoids the need for an external
javascript file and we have a reference
to uh sort of the the detailed
documentation uh on the github site for
haste that sort of explains the details
of how this ffi mechanism works under
the hood but most of the libraries that
we've seen on github that are wrapping
javascript libraries are using the ffi
style it's just easier to work with
because you don't need to
to use these external or bind these
external functions right in a javascript
file directly
so let's talk about the other direction
briefly let's say that you want to write
a library using haste that you're going
to compile down to javascript and you
want to use that compiled output in some
other javascript program you're going to
import that compiled output in a script
using a script tag and and call into
some function that you've implemented
so the way that works uh is that you
write your haskell file so we have
export.hs
and we're defining an addend function
here
and then in our main we're
exporting that so we're saying that we
want to make the add-in function
available externally and that's going to
cause the compiler to generate slightly
different output
and in this example we're just going to
show
you know sort of an html file that is
going to invoke that but it's going to
invoke it using uh some javascript code
that we are also including in so in this
example export js is our compiled output
from haste and calc js is just this
other file that we authored by hand
that's doing sort of the same work that
we were doing on that on the haskell
side in the previous example
and so if we look at calc js you know
we're sort of doing the same stuff that
we did previously in in haskell we're
grabbing these elements
values from the dom but you'll notice
that line there where we say sum equals
hey stot add end so
the functions that you export
from haste are at compile time are
placed in this haste namespace for you
and then you just call into those uh
using those parameters and that's it um
and then there's some compiler machinery
that you need to invoke to get that to
work properly um and that's the command
line there but but that's the basic
mechanics of
using the ffi the other direction
right
okay so uh you build all this machinery
at the ffi you write a bunch of code
with uh with haste and now you've got
some errors and you're trying to figure
out how to debug these errors you want
to write some tests to prove that your
code were or to you know try to
demonstrate some give yourself some
sanity that your code is working a
little bit um so what are you to do
the good news is that uh the haste the
implementation of the some of these like
functions you're gonna be using provided
by haste give you some error handling
out of the box for instance that with
elem thing that we were doing all the
time if i pass it the string bar and all
i have in the dom is an element with id
of foo i get a totally sensible error
message saying like no element with id
bar can be found that's totally great
but if i do some other stupid er stuff
like let's say i uh naively pattern
match el excuse me i naively assume that
ln by d bar is going to get me back
something adjust
and all i got in the the dom is an
element with idea foo when i run this
stuff i'm going to get an error from
deep inside the bowels of the compiled
javascript code and wobi he or she that
can diagnose what an uncaught pound t is
and you don't really have the help of
your debugger because as i said this is
compiled code and to achieve the call
semantics of haskell but in javascript
the compiled code is going to look so
different from anything you're familiar
to um that's setting a debugger point in
there and trying to step through it and
my experience has not been a
particularly
fruitful adventure
for instance
main equals alert hello in addition to
the bajillion lines of the boilerplate
generated by haste
this is what the compiled code is going
to look like so you may be smarter than
me that's probably true but i had a very
difficult time even in this simple
example sort of stepping through and
understanding what was going on so what
i end up using all the time is write log
which is essentially an alias to
console.log i feel like i sort of time
warped back like eight ten years or
whatever but you know it's sort of the
it's sort of the way that
it's the price that i'm currently paying
to be able to write haskell that
compiles the javascript i'm keeping my
little tiny fingers crossed for source
maps but i'm not aware of uh of any work
that's going into that right now
um when it comes to testing
you're writing you're writing haskell
right some of this haskell compiles to
javascript but if you're able to
separate
the code that doesn't know anything
about haste from the code that doesn't
know everything about haste for instance
this add function which i've
externalized in math stuff.hs
you can test it as if it were just
regular haskell james had an interesting
observation about the types of this
you want to talk about i bet you do want
to talk about it well why don't you
give the example then i'll explain the
edge case okay so anyways like this math
stuff uh we're exporting only one
function add which goes from integer to
integer to integer it's a binary
function that takes like an x and a y
and returns x plus y
um my haste code uh
alert is um being called with the result
of the call to show
which is being you know like the
add 10 20 is going to be 30 i'm going to
pass that to show and then the result of
that is going to go to alert
so i'm testing the haskell code
independently from the haste code and i
can use h-spec which is a pretty common
uh bdd-ish uh the api feels very similar
to bdd testing frameworks that you may
have used in like ruby or whatever like
rspec or something like that
um
and it just basically comes down to my
experience of separating like the code
that is just regular haskell code from
the code that is very like hasty and if
it's really important to you to test
your haste code that hits the dom and so
on and so forth like i have just used uh
higher level tools like capybara or
whatever to just assert that my web
application is functioning in in some
way and then i use h-spec to test all
the pure stuff underneath the hood
yeah so the caveat that was there is is
simply the fact that um when you're
using something like h spec and you run
that on the command line you're not
using haste at all
right so you're you're writing this code
in haskell and you're using the ghc
compiler and you're running h-spec and
that's never hitting a browser right
that's never that's not running through
any javascript runtime and we picked
this example and we were looking at it
last night and we were like you know
integer is like the worst thing we could
have picked right because the actual
runtime representation of an integer
in in haskell via ghc is very different
than a number in javascript right so a
number in javascript is what this will
end up being when you run it in a web
browser which is just a ieee floating
point um but in in haskell an integer is
an arbitrary big int like it's like a
resizable infinite you know so we could
we could author some tests that work
here with really really really large
numbers and they'll pass h spec and if
you ran them in the browser you'd get
integer overflows right so
um that's one thing to be aware of if
you use tools like h-spec to test pure
code is that some of the type uh
information is not the same right the
run time that you're running in in a
browser you just have to be a little
cognizant of that and i think for most
you know stuff that we're writing
probably not going to hit those kinds of
conditions but it's something to be
aware of right so we just wanted to
point that out totally
oh yeah you talk about hackage okay so
uh
haskell has a uh a package repository
called hackage that's very similar to
pi pi or or gems or npm
and
you can use that with haste so this is
similar if you've ever used a tool like
browserify with javascript
to
package manage your client-side
javascript code you'll be familiar with
the idea of like you could write a
javascript library and upload it to npm
even though it's not going to be used
with node
the same idea is true with with haskell
you're
totally it's totally okay to write a
package that uses haste uh in haskell
and upload it to hackage and conversely
you can download those packages from
package and use them in your projects
the one caveat when you're downloading
the packages is that you need to use the
tool that haste provides
called haste inst instead of using the
cabal command and the cabal command is
just the tool that you use on the
command line to fetch packages from
hackage
so for example the right way to do this
is to hasten stall haste perch not cabal
install haste approach and this has to
do with some uh compilation step that
that haste is going to introduce when it
downloads a package so it's going to
download that package and it's going to
compile
the haskell code in there into an
intermediate format that it's going to
use when you link against it from your
programs that you write
that use it from haste
okay cool so after you know the last
several months of working with haste i
have like a wish list um so if any of
you out there feel particularly
compelled to go build some stuff that i
can consume in my projects i would
totally appreciate it such as a source
map implementation
a higher level dom api a higher level a
higher level api for working with the
dom um there's a project out there uh
haste jquery um
alberto corona has haste perch which is
promising as well but as you were seeing
or excuse me as you saw in those slides
i'm working at a very low level and it
could be a bit cumbersome um i'm also
hoping that uh the examples we put
together there are bajillion more in
addition to the things we've shown you
in these slides of just doing the basics
like the stuff that i have to do in my
job every day in building a web
application i want to see those examples
and i'd prefer to see even more of those
things combined together and bigger and
bigger and bigger applications being
built if nothing else for some
inspiration as to like how i would build
a larger system using haste
um some projects to watch uh sort of
like the the tri-ruby of haste is
alberto corona's
tryplayge.herocoap.com it's called uh hg
playground i recommend you check it out
he's also the guy that wrote perch
alfredo di napoli has haste jquery and
haste bootstrap to get you sort of up
and running and then nathan soreson's uh
shade library uses react under the hood
um i i think it's a super promising
project uh he i don't know how long he's
been working on it for but i highly
recommend you check it out and follow
him on twitter he's got some pretty
interesting things to say
um so that's it haste full stack haskell
i hope that these slides were not super
confusing and in spite of the fact that
this is all haskell you looked at it and
you said i can kind of figure out how
this works
i would suggest if haskell is something
that is interesting to you check out the
brett yorgi cis194 university of
pennsylvania course i thought it was
really good good examples uh good
assignments good lectures so on and so
forth
and get out there and try it out and
send me a message on twitter and let me
know what you think
thanks
we have like
basically totally run out of time it's
like four minutes we have four minutes
four minutes oh well do you have any
good stump to speaker type questions
that i can't answer
yeah what's up
yeah sorry no i've been like micro
machining through this project so i'm
trying to like finish it by the end of
the time um it's brett yorgi cis194
university of pennsylvania yeah right
exactly i thought that like of all the
resources i came across towards learning
haskell that was the best like
introductory course um the assignments
were challenging enough that it really
forced me to like grok some of the
concepts um i found that when i was
reading like learn you a haskell that
like i had a superficial understanding
of some of these abstractions but when i
actually tried to like type stuff into
the computer and make it work or
understand like real library code it
wasn't deep enough for me so highly
recommend the brett yorkie course
why
not cool
is there anybody else out there
yeah what's up in the back
uh rough workflow with haste um
oh a rebel with haste uh no the closest
thing that i've gotten if i want to just
like sort of play around and i can't use
ghci is that h playground uh thing that
alberto corona put together um but for
the most part like if i need to sort of
figure out how all the types and such
are going to line up i import packages
uh i import stuff into ghci and just
manipulate them in the reple
and i just sort of like incrementally
apply uh arguments or excuse me
functions arguments until i can sort of
like make sense of the types
if i want to see how that actually shows
up yeah each playground is is uh is the
way to go
cool thank you for your time enjoy the
rest your conference